fable 3 is all about power man it's all
about you feeling powerful there's three
ways that we're talking about about
about power the first way is the story
you know every story pretty much while I
see on TV I'm watching the cinema or a
play in a computer game is the same it's
called the hero's journey it starts off
where you're an insignificant nothing
there's a big baddie you build up enough
power to take on the big baddie you
defeat the big baddie end a film end of
book end of computer game why is it
always like that where the most
interesting thing is what happens after
the battle so in papal 3 half the game
is the hero's journey half the game is
being that weak person at the start
being the big Tyrone hood King your
building and our followers up you
overthrow the king and then the other
half the game is what it's like to be
king the next thing that we're talking
about is something called touch well now
we've given you the ability to touch
people as you can reach out your hand
and when you first meet someone you
shake their hand after a while if it's a
romantic connection you're making you
end up hugging that person and then
kissing that person if you don't like
the person then touching them you can
grab them by the scruff of the neck and
you can drag them and then they'll be
they'll be making you feel guilty as you
drag them that is another expression of
power because it is no longer based
around choices about pressing the a
button or the B button you are
physically doing those things those are
powerful things and the last is about
the combat you know combat and two games
like fable of really
important this was all about power but
we really wanted to give you something
new so the new thing in combat is the
ability for you to craft your own
weapons when you first get a weapon it's
like a blank sheet of paper and as you
put as you wheel that weapon and as you
straight with that weapon that weapon
will change to reflect the way you
fought so your weapon is you as unique
as you are you are then after a while
free to sell and trade that weapon
online